foreign
let's move on to social media questions
we got one from Facebook from Alabama
that's right we have a question from
Paula she says what can I do with old
birthday cards signed with notes from
deceased relatives the only time I look
at them is when I'm packing up all my
stuff to move to a new home but I feel
awful about throwing them away of course
one of the things you can do is have a
photo scanning party or a card scanning
party it's in our minimalist rule book
you can download it for free the
minimalists.com
rulebook and one of the things in there
is a photo scanning party now we just
call a party because if you put party at
the end of anything Ryan shows up I'll
bring the beer
and so uh we did this with our we share
a photo scanner in fact and so because I
had all these photo albums and boxes and
bins full of just haphazard
miscellaneous and a lot of it was photos
and cards and photos of people I didn't
even know who were in the photos but if
you have a photo scanning party you
bring some folks over and you look
through the photos together it starts to
conjure up these stories you realize
that most of the photos you're holding
on to or most of the cards you're
holding up onto you're never going to
access them ever and you can even
discard those without scanning them but
we would just feed them through a
scanner we'll put a link actually
podcast Sean if you can put a link to
the photo scanner that we use in the
show notes over at the minimalists.com
podcast if that's helpful for folks that
way you can actually sit down and turn
this thing that is mundane boring
Dreadful into something more enjoyable
if you bring three or four friends over
and you're looking at these cards
together or maybe they're family members
who would enjoy discussing these cards
with you right and you can scan them and
that way you still have access to them
in fact you have more access to them
because they can't get lost in a flood
or a fire if you have double your
redundancy backed up like I do on my
photos
but now you have access to them without
needing to hold on to the physical items
themselves one other thing I do I have
one file
uh file folder with some photos in it
and so there's a hand but that's my
boundary it can't go beyond that file
folder and if I get more than that then
I'm gonna have to get rid of the access
yeah
um yeah setting up boundaries for
yourself is really important I mean a
piece of me is like Paula why are you I
mean if the cards bring you Joy then
keep them hang on to them
um but there's clearly some kind of
discomfort or pain happening when she
thinks about holding on to these
physical cards I know it's difficult to
throw away or recycle something that
someone gave you especially someone that
you really really love and cherish
especially someone you love and really
really cherish and then they're not
there anymore so you know oh this is the
last car that so-and-so gave me and it
feels like when you throw that card out
it feels like oh I'm throwing that
person out or I'm throwing the
relationship out and that's just not the
case and I learned this after my packing
party where I got rid of some letters
that meant a lot to me that my mom wrote
me during high school and I scanned it
um you know didn't want to like let go
of of of of that piece of paper because
it really represented something
meaningful to me
um I put in the trash and I was like
well if I get up the next morning
morning I can just get up and you know
if it's bothering me that much and I'm
missing it that much I can just get up
and grab that letter off the top of the
trash and keep it and you know I didn't
even think about it the next day there
was a a point where I had to say goodbye
um and that was difficult but after I
said goodbye it really it really wasn't
something that I was missing constantly
yeah yeah because as we often say like
in our last Netflix film our memories
are not in our things our memories are
inside us and the person is not in those
things either and so yes these things
can trigger the memories that are inside
us that's why the photo scanning party
works or taking a picture of a physical
item works because you don't lose the
trigger of the memory but you don't have
to hold on to the thing if it's getting
in the way for you
yeah
I remember when I was 20 my uh my best
friend from childhood he passed away
heart failure playing basketball no no
previous conditions or anything like
that and I remember you know when when
we buried his body and and there's that
moment where the coffin begins to
descend uh I I I just felt terrible
because I felt like we're all about to
leave my friend here you know we're
about to leave him here and we're about
to go back to our lives and figure out
you know what we're gonna do about work
the next day what we're gonna do about
eating and running our errands and he's
going to be left here and what gave me
the the consolation and the strength was
recognizing that no that's that's not my
friend we're leaving behind
you know my friend already left and and
we're doing this to honor the fact that
he was here and it was that
understanding that gave me the strength
to walk away and I think it's
interesting that when
someone we love gives us a birthday card
and then they pass away we have an
easier time burying the bodies than the
things that they left behind we don't
feel like we're throwing the body away
but we feel like we're throwing the
person away if we bury a card and that's
probably because we have a few
narratives going on number one we
understand that the person is not the
body and keeping that body around isn't
the same thing as keeping the person
around we also understand that if you
keep that person around that body around
it's going to make it harder to let go
of the aspects of your life with them
that you know that you need to let go
and also quite frankly it's going to
start becoming a distraction in a way
that makes it difficult for you to enjoy
the memories of them that you should
focus on and there's something similar
going on with things if the things
you're holding on to from a deceased
loved one if they're starting to burden
you if they're starting to annoy you if
you're starting to wrestle with throwing
them away then now that's becoming a
distraction from all of the wonderful
memories that you could be having about
them by all means keep the things that
bring you Joy and that bring you meaning
but one thing that you could do in
addition to scanning them if these
things are burdening you and weighing
you down is you could
bury them and have a funeral for them
ritualize it say goodbye to them create
a eulogy for those things that that
person left you and if these are
birthday cards you can either so you can
even say hey on my birthday or maybe the
eve of my birthday I'm gonna come back
to the burial spot wow whatever it may
be or or just wherever I am I'm gonna
take a few moments and I'm gonna thank
that person for being part of my life
and for shaping the history of my
birthdays and the way that they did that
could be a meaningful way to not only
let this stuff go but to also keep alive
the memories that this stuff symbolizes
anyway and that have kind of become lost
amidst the distractions of it feeling
like a burden did you enjoy this
Standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalists private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free